ورشه والاصلاح البولنديه السريه للاسلحه
الاوكرانيه المتعطله توصف بالتحدي الاكبر
في هذه الحرب ففي مصنع بحجم ملعب كره
القدم تحيط به مباني المهجوره يعمل مئات
الفنيين لاصلاح المدفعيه والدروع الثقيله
واعادتها الى خط المواجهه عبر الطريق الذي
شهد اكبر عمليه نقل الاسلحه في اوروبا منذ
الحرب العالميه الثانيه الفنيون داخل
المصنع وعددهم 400 تقريبا يعملون في ثلاث
نبات على مدار الساعه وهم على اتصال
المنتظم بالاوكرانيين في ساحه المعركه فهم
يعلمونهم عبر التطبيقات المشفره افضل
التقنيات للاصلاحات سواء الدبابات او
الصواريخ وكيفيه اكتشاف المشكلات اصلاح كل
سلاح قد يستغرق شهرين تجتاز هذه الاسلحه
فحوصات امنيه قبل السماح لها بالصعود الى
ارضيه المصنع ويراقب الورشه ضبا مسلحون من
جهاز الامن الداخلي مكلفين طبعا بالكشف عن
عمليات تخريب محتمله طالت سابقا مصانع
اسلحه في دول اخرى بينها بلغاريا كما تشمل
قواعد الورشه ان يكون كل فرد من موظفي
التجمع والتجميع والانتاج واي زائر للمبنى
سيكون مواطنا بولنديا ما يعني استغراق اي
عمليه فرز لموظفين جدد بغض النظر عن
الرتبه اشهر عداء تحدي صيامه واصلاح ذخائر
سيزيد تعقيدا مع قرب وصول الدبابات
الغربيه الى ساحه المعارك والمقدر عددها ب
100 وثلاثين على ان يتم اصلاح دبابات
ابرامز في مدينه بوزنان وفقا ترجيحات
وبحسب طبعا مسؤولين بولنديين الورشه قد
تتوسع قريبا لاصلاح وصيانه المعدات
المصنعه في الخارج
[موسيقى]